[Applaudissements]
aulas
le jour se lève
comme dans un
2e
jean
un besoin
comme jamais
[Musique]
ton voyage
je voulais pas
comme si j'avais écouté la terre j'ai
trouvé mon dieu
mais
pas
[Musique]
je suis un losange joachim clave main et
15 vous serez clint field
je laisse la main marie martin non on
l'a tous fait chier simon tu prends la
main pour progrès alors je vous dis
c'est d'abord je vais pas faire emmerder
pour donnant cyclo pj sur les cormorans
jeu fabre de lavage comprendra pas
[Musique]
hélas
alors hier soir il y avait top chef et y
en a un qui est très énervé c'est gilles
verdez qu'est ce que ce passe encore non
ta merde de la merde dont j'ai pas
regardé mais la merde ya dix ans j'ai
mal à ma france sont prêts à tout j'ai
mal à ma france et avilissant vraiment
la merde
[Applaudissements]